I'm here, because I made a promise.
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of that new
preview that Marvel just dropped of the
dark version of Captain America everyone
was wondering what's going on with that
it's for the Falcon in Winter Soldier
series so we'll break it down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
also doing that infinity saga box set
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about Thunderbolt Ross and the
Thunderbolts during Marvel phase 4
so we'll just break this down top 7
style starting with number 7 this is
John Walker u.s. agent in a couple
different scenes that they were filming
recently so Marvel just released this he
was out publicly so of course people
were going to find out about it usually
when they have to film outside with the
actors Marvel will wind up releasing
stuff like this so the people can see it
looking much better than the jenkees
cellphone picks that usually wind up
floating around like when we saw Tom
Hollands a new spider-man far from home
spider-man suit he had all that janky
footage then they put him on Jimmy
Kimmel just to show everyone yes this is
the new costume this is what it's going
to look like during the film you saw all
that crappy footage now see what it
looks like when it's nice and shiny
so everyone saw this and they're like
what's going on why does he have Captain
America's shield what are they doing
during Falcon and Winter Soldier first
he's wearing his military dress uniform
then it seems like there's some short
time jump and they're filming a slightly
different scene with him in a version of
Captain America's costume wielding cap
shield after the events of Avengers end
game real meta Easter egg here that
person that's playing this character
John Walker from the comics is actually
named Wyatt Russell in real life he's
the son of Kurt Russell who played ego
the Living Planet back during guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 most of you also
probably noticed the costume Easter egg
from the comics so the costume that he's
wearing which is made to be a version of
a Captain America suit is designed to
look like his comic book u.s. agent suit
so number 6 when does he get the shield
why does he get the shield brief plot
synopsis of the series because he is
basically the government's version of
Captain America after the events of
Avengers endgame so think about
Thunderbolt Ross being behind all this
you start with the Avengers end game
ending where Captain America gives
Falcon the shield notice the notches in
it so he's obviously polished it a
little bit in the years he's been away
in that alternate timeline with Peggy
Carter
but then at some point during the events
of Falcon and Winter Soldier Thunderbolt
Ross takes the shield away from Falcon
because he did not sign the sokovia
accords back during Captain America
Civil War remember Falcon was teamcap
the whole way they all got thrown in the
raft by Thunderbolt Ross as war
criminals that at the end of the movie
Captain America just broke them out of
that prison they all went on the run to
become the Secret Avengers from the
comics on the DL you have the events of
Avengers infinity war the snap
then Avengers end game happens and
because Falcon was snapped there was no
need for a Thunderbolt Ross or anybody
that wasn't snapped to go after him and
try and Rhea rest him throw him back in
the raft but just because the snap
happened and they defeated Thanos
doesn't mean that they all get this
blanket pardon so number 5 at the end of
Avengers endgame you have Thunderbolt
Ross attending Iron Man's funeral with
everyone else the dust has settled he
comes back to them like the assh*le that
he is so look about that business with
the sokovia accords we're still going to
need you to sign those and play by our
rules the world security council pretty
safe bet that Falcons not going to want to
do that just because he feels like
Captain America didn't believe in that
in mentally morally he's kind of a what
would cap do person
so if cap didn't believe in what
Thunderbolt Ross was doing didn't want
to sign the Accords then neither is
Falcon going to do that so that's
probably when the government and
Thunderbolt Ross take the shield back
from him they kind of had a moment like
that during Civil War two in the comics
where a u.s. agent comes for Falcon
who's already picked up the shield and
got his new Captain America costume with
the wings u.s. agent tries to take the
shield back from him for the government
because technically even though kind of
sucks the US government is the one that
owns Captain America's shield because it
was developed by Howard Stark for the
military and then given to Captain
America by the military so then you have
this moment here where they want their
version of Captain America to rally the
public around and hold up as this sign
the same way that they did during
Captain America in World War two like
look at this symbol of peace he's
helping everyone but it's basically the
government stooge version of Captain
America the reason why I think of him as
a darker version of Captain America is
because when they introduced the John
Walker character in the comics he was
introduced as his hardliner sort of
darkest timeline version of Captain
America but imagine the war crimes
version of Captain America like this
person did a lot of questionable things
during these wards is he really the
right person to give the shield to he's
not quite right in the head so just
because something goes dark early theory
Baron Zemo eventually breaks out of
prison because Baron Zemo is the main
villain of the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series he takes advantage of the
situation and there's this worldwide
plot it's meant to be this global threat
that Baron Zemo poses so theory
continues that's when Falcon and Winter
Soldier at the team-up with Sharon
Carter who's sort of their person on the
inside of the world Security Council
working with Thunderbolt Ross she's
probably the person that finds out about
what's going on with u.s. agent like
look they're going to take the shield back
from you and give it to this asshole
over here they have to team up
separately from Thunderbolt Ross to take
down Baron Zemo and fix whatever
problems u.s. agent dark Captain America
causes when he messes up then at the end
of the series I think the idea is is
that Thunderbolt Ross will finally allow
Falcon to keep the shield and he gets
his new costume at some point during
that this is what Bucky's new costume
and Falcons new costumes are going to
look like but I don't know when during
the episodes they're going to get that
they'll be six episodes total of Falcon
and Winter Soldier all the Marvel
Avengers Disney Plus series will be six
episodes unless you hear otherwise so
the number four if they're tying all
this stuff in setting up big movie stuff
the stuff that happens at the end of
Falcon a Winter Soldier to tease big
changes in the MCU besides Falcon just
getting to keep the shield is also Baron
Zemo and u.s. agent then being recruited
to the Thunderbolts by Thunderbolt Ross
but number three next big question
clearly it looks like US agent gets some
sort of powers where does he get them
from do they have another version of the
Super Soldier Serum it might wind up
being another derivative of the Super
Soldier serum like Thunderbolt Ross gave
to Emil Blonsky aka the abomination
during Incredible Hulk remember early in
the movie when Blonsky got so Rashed by
the hook and they just kept pumping him
full of that special derivative serum
that they had developed
so just because no one's been able to
perfectly replicate the Super Soldier
Serum that they gave to Captain America
there are other governments like the
Black Widow program in the Red Room that
developed derivatives to that really
good example that we'll see during the
Black Widow movie sort of connecting
Falcon and Winter Soldier to the
flashbacks in Black Widow the Red
Guardian character played by David
Harbor who's sort of like the dragon
ball fusion of Thicke Thor and Captain
America is basically the Soviet version
of Captain America he was given another
derivative as a Super Soldier Serum that
they gave to Captain America not the
same thing not quite as good but still
pretty good remember during Captain
America Civil War that's also what they
gave to all those other winter soldiers
that they were creating that were in
stasis so the Soviets during the Cold
War were able to steal and develop their
own version of the Super Soldier Serum
even though it's not quite the same
thing so everybody kind of has their own
version of that number two what's
going on with the MCU Thunderbolts who
would be on that team does this have
some connection to the Black Widow movie
post-credit scene with some sort of
Thunderbolt Ross taskmasters storyline
Hurley there are a bunch of villains
that could join the Thunderbolts that
have been members of the team in the
comics previously but most likely ones
would be Thunderbolt Ross obviously
being the dark Nick Fury of that team
giving them their marching orders Baron
Zemo leading the team they're talking
about how Falcon a Winter Soldier is
supposed to set up Thunderbolts in the
MCU so it makes sense that Baron Zemo is
the first person recruited to that team
taskmaster from the Black Widow movie
maybe Yelena Belova from Black Widow
if she doesn't wind up dying at the end
of that movie there's the ghost from
ant-man and the wasp still has badass
powers but much better control them
after the events of that movie the
Winter Soldier he still wanted for war
crimes and he hasn't been pardoned by
the government yet in maybe u.s. agent
if they don't wind up killing him off at
the end of Falcon in Winter Soldier then
big number one future Thunderbolts
Disney Plus Series B six episodes just
like all the other Disney Plus series in
a template for how they developed their
Young Avengers project eventually once
they introduced enough characters the
MCU Thunderbolts team isn't going to be
that huge mostly four or five people
probably at any given
time and maybe at least one red shirt
that they kill off during the first
season of Thunderbolts whenever that
winds up happening
maybe maybe outside chance for
Thunderbolt Ross finally becoming Red
Hulk during that series but that also
feels like a really really big deal they
might save it for one of the movies
we'll probably get the full Falcon and
Winter Soldier trailer at least by the
summer but it'll be the very first
Avengers series on Disney Plus then
they'll premiere one division then the
mandalorian season two and then the
other Disney Plus series next year in
related Marvel news everyone click here
to learn about the big Marvel phase for
Doctor Strange x-men announcement and
click here for my brand new Morbius trailer
sinister six Easter eggs video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!